this is so funny it's one of the most
cringe-worthy FoxNews moments I've seen
in a long time
and that's a very very high bar to reach
if you've ever watched Fox News Fox News
has this commentator or analyst named
Katie Pavlich Katie Pavlich is 30 years
old she's a quote conservative and most
importantly she's extraordinarily
ignorant she kind of as a conservative
star in a way she was named blogger of
the Year by CPAC she is all sorts of
these low information propaganda books
that right-wing audiences loved one
called fast and furious Barack Obama's
bloodiest scandal and it's shameless
cover up another book assault and
flattery the truth about the left and
their war on women this is the type of
thing that she has written she's a
totally irresponsible
interviewer she interviewed Andrew
Pollock who's the father of one of the
victims of the Parkland school shooting
on Fox News some time ago the father
falsely claimed that Democrats were
registering criminals in Florida jails
to vote Pavelec didn't even challenge
the could the claim didn't say how do
you know that didn't say well do you
have any evidence that that's going on
completely irresponsible interviewer as
well so she appears on Fox News
yesterday and she makes the bizarre and
obviously false and also just really
dumb claim that America should be held
up as a beacon of anti slavery because
we were the first country to end slavery
within the first hundred and fifty years
of being a country which is both really
specific really irrelevant and also
wrong I mean it's just ridiculous in
every sense and this was so obviously
idiotic that a fellow Fox News host who
I believe goes by Kennedy and I don't
know if Kennedy is her first name or her
last name or both her first name and
last name I'm not really sure or just
kind of like a nickname I'm not sure
Kennedy has to say what the f are you
talking about let's take a look at the
video they they keep blaming America for
the sin of slavery but the truth is
throughout human history slavery has
existed and America came along as the
first country to end it within a hundred
and fifty years and we get no credit for
the
to move forward and try and we did have
a very bloody civil war over the racial
entry and limits of the Civil War right
particularly blacks in the south right
yeah that was not it was bloody and
violent and deadly and there were Native
Americans that we all of that a country
that decided to end it and we're still
dealing with the issue but if you want
to start a problem and to inflame racial
tension even more start blaming people
who have nothing to do with slavery for
the sin of slavery that is not fair
that's not the American Way and we
shouldn't be doing it yeah so we'll talk
about America being the first country to
ban slavery within a hundred and fifty
years of existence but first of all half
the country wanted slavery and went to
war to keep slavery and threatened to
leave the Union over wanting to keep
slavery and the people who stick to that
ideology today are all Republicans
they're all on the right okay so she's
calling the banning of slavery in the US
and achievement which it is it's the
right thing to do banning slavery is
good but it's one that was made by
people who opposed the right wing of
that time when we were going into the
Civil War phase of the United States and
as Kennedy correctly points out just
because slavery ended the path for black
people in the United States remained
difficult to use her framing an
understatement for a very long time it
created structural inequality that
persists today she says don't blame
people who have nothing to do with
slavery for slavery okay fine
what about recognizing that slavery was
ended not because the u.s. decided to
end slavery but because the Union was
able to defeat a huge portion of the
country which was the slave owning South
which wanted to keep slavery legal so
that's part one now let's discuss her
other claim that the United States
should get credit for being able to so
quickly ban slavery it only took a
hundred and fifty years after the
creation of the country this information
exists in in history books right the
timeline between independence and
slavery for different countries is far
shorter than in the United States
you can debate well what do we count as
banning slavery when you ban the slave
trade are you banning the owning of
slaves we could sort of find different
data points but there are countries that
ban slavery before they were even really
countries Denmark is an example slave
trade banned in 1803 didn't become it's
sort of original constitutional monarchy
until 18-49 another example is my birth
country of Argentina Argentina banned
slavery in 1853 it was founded in 1810
that's just 43 years between
independence and ending slavery so it's
hard to sometimes even do an analysis of
this stuff Pat because it's so obviously
wrong but it's also so obviously
ignorant and it's also so obviously
irrelevant that it's stunning that it's
even allowed to sort of go only mildly
contested in the way that it often is
yeah wrong ignorant irrelevant I also
wonder why she wants to even make this
point on the left right now in the
Democratic primary we're having a
conversation about reparations for
slavery Julian Castro is making that a
pillar of his campaign and meanwhile on
Fox and Friends were talking about
whether or not the United States
deserves any credit for eventually
ending slavery after a bloody civil war
so I think that's just the state of the
country right now yeah and and you know
the the reparations conversation you
could be for or against reparations in
2019 and be a reasonable person and and
sort of have a sensible debate you
should be able to without question point
out that Katie Pavlich is wrong by both
the letter and the spirit of what she's
saying it's embarrassing and most
importantly it's a dumb point because
when the United States banned slavery
half the country didn't want to and
thought that it was worth going to war
over keeping slavery incredible
irrational ignorant happening on fox
news daily make sure to follow the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show while you're there follow me at
David Pakman quick break and we will
talk the Denise Hearn next it will be a
very interesting
conversation we've now been taking
pretty seriously for more than a year
the topic of Donald Trump's possible
cognitive decline and sort of fitness to
be President of the United States we
recently had dr. John Gartner
psychiatrist from Johns Hopkins Medical
Center back on the program he believes
that Donald Trump is in some combination
of a pre dementia State combined with
some cognitive limitation or disorder
and possible personality disorders we've
been observing this kind of disordered
speech and disordered thinking for a
long time now
ignorance combined with very confused
attacks on people and things that don't
really seem to make sense for a normal
adult in a position of Donald similar to
that in which Donald Trump finds himself
and we have now growing concern
including even from Kellyanne Conway's
husband George Conway who commented
about this stuff over the weekend we had
a period of several hours over the
weekend where Donald Trump went on a
very unusual even for his standard
spiral of idiocy that has brought
forward even more concerns about the
state of Donald Trump's mental mental
health and and sort of cognitive
abilities first Donald Trump tweeted
about a Saturday Night Live episode that
wasn't even new it was a rerun but
Donald Trump found himself angrily sort
of responding to it on Twitter over the
weekend saying quote it's truly
incredible that shows like Saturday
Night Live not funny
/ no talent can spend all of their time
knocking the same person me over and
over without so much of a mention of the
other side like an advertisement without
consequences same with late-night shows
and of course you know that this is
notable for a couple of different
reasons
the microfocus from this president on
specific shows shows on Fox News
Saturday Night Live Jimmy Kimmel whoever
that's unusual to begin with but even
further it's also not true what he's
saying the late-night shows and Saturday
Night Live will pair
all sorts of different people it may be
that Donald Trump is particularly sort
of thin-skinned and so he's only
impacted by or remembering the critiques
or parodies of himself and then he went
on to attack the late Senator John
McCain who of course passed away of
brain cancer just months ago in a
completely unintelligible tweet but
certainly an attack on John McCain quote
so it was indeed just proven in court
papers quote last in his class
parentheses annapolis john mccain that
sent the quote he capitalized fake
dossier to the FBI and capital m media
hoping to have it printed before the
capital e election he and the Dems
working together failed parenthesis as
usual even the capitalized fake news
refused this garbage do you understand
what he's saying here pat is the
criticism that mccain had bad grades
thus his role in forwarding the steel
dossier is to be questioned or something
like that we may have to go over the
tweet a couple more times for me to
fully understand it because i'm just so
lost by the syntax and the erroneous use
of capitalization maybe we can go over
it again yeah III truly don't understand
it and we probably need a full bonus
show actually to figure out what that
one meant but extraordinarily weird then
Trump started complaining about the
weekend hosts on Fox News also slamming
Shepard Smith who as I pointed out
before is basically the lone voice of
reason on fox news during the week you
occasionally then will get Chris Wallace
saying something remotely intelligible
and logical on weekends Donald Trump
tweeting again the same barrage of
tweets over the weekend were Fox News
weekend anchors arthel neville and
Leland Vitter trained by CNN prior to
their ratings collapse in any event
that's where they should be working
along with their lowest rated anchor
Shepard Smith of course just hours
before this tweet Trump was tweeting
positive things about Fox News go figure
not just yet another one of the con
addictions and then Trump demanded that
that crazy judge Jeanine Pirro be bought
brought back on the air at Fox News
after she was suspended over some
comments that Fox understood to be
Islamophobic he went on a three tweet
rant related to Jeanine Pirro where he
said quote bring back judge Jeanine
Pirro the radical left Democrats working
closely with their beloved partner the
fake news media is using every trick in
the book to silence a majority of our
our capital C country they have all-out
campaigns against Fox News hosts who are
doing too well Fox must stay strong and
fight back with vigor stop working so
hard on being politically correct which
will only bring you down and continue to
fight our country the losers all want
what you have don't give it to them be
strong and prosper be weak and die stay
true to the people that got you there
keep fighting for Tucker and fight by
the way
Tucker's fine fighting for Tucker and
fight hard for judge Jeanine your
competitors are jealous they all want
what you've got number one don't hand it
to them on a silver platter they can't
beat you you can only beat yourselves
it's almost like if an inspirational
speaker lost all sense of what mattered
and how to speak this is what you would
you would effectively end up with and
it's truly amazing how much attention
FoxNews gets from the president I mean
that's that's a remarkable thing the
amount that the president is watching
Fox News the amount that the president
is basing his public narrative and
discourse on Twitter on what happens to
be on fox news when he turns it on that
he's making specific programming demands
about bring back Janine and get rid of
Leland Vitter who by the way was the guy
I appeared with when I was on Fox News
very unusual stuff and then at some
point I mean no Trump Twitter rant is
complete without criticizing the Moller
investigation which he did do saying
quote report Christopher Steele backed
up his Democrat and crooked Hillary paid
for fake and unverified dossier within
he got from quote send in Watchers
unquote of low rating CNN this is the
info that got us the witch-hunt
and then he went on to reference some
vague insurance policy that he believes
Democrats have against them I think he's
mentioned this before and he calls the
multiple investigations against his
possible crimes an insurance policy he
tweeted quote when the demek what the
Democrats have done in trying to steal a
presidential election first at the
ballot box and then after that failed
with the quote insurance policy is the
biggest capital S scandal in the history
of our capital C country so
understandably many more mental health
professionals expressing concern as a
result of this rant even right-wingers
expressing concern Kellyanne Conway's
husband George Conway saying that
there's a mental condition here that
applies and that it seems to be getting
worse not that surprising given that
just last week Trump was angry with auto
pilot on airplanes raging against
complicated aircraft and I actually I
want to be clear I don't think this is a
funny thing that we laugh at this is
serious it seems that something is truly
sort of acutely wrong with the President
of the United States and at this point
there's one path out and that's voting
in 2020 impeachment might be the right
thing and if it is go ahead and try it
but it would take a long time you need
Republicans to be on board and I don't
think they're going to be removal under
the 25th amendment by the Cabinet
justified at this point good luck making
that a reality so the if you're sick of
this the path forward is vote the guy
out period because we cannot count on
Republicans to help us remove him that
would be necessary for impeachment that
would be necessary for a removal under
the 25th amendment it's voting in
November of 2020 period that is it no
matter what anybody else tells you let
me know your reaction to this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show follow us
both and we'll be right back after this
I was actually going to cover this
story earlier in today's show except
then Trump's violent rhetoric was
actually linked to a specific shooting
the one in New Zealand but shortly
before the shooting in New Zealand
Donald Trump issued the type of threat
that we hear from authoritarian
dictators about using the police and the
military to crack down against political
opponents which is of course completely
antithetical to everything that the
United States stands for or at least
should stand for this actually wasn't
noticed for a few days
Donald Trump gave an interview to
Breitbart it was early last week in fact
and at a certain point in this interview
he said supporters of his might get
tough on people who oppose him
politically this includes the military
this includes the police and this
includes biker gangs now I'm going to
show you
bright Bart's own transcript of what
Trump said this isn't a summary this
isn't some left-wing website rephrasing
what Donald Trump said this is bright
Bart's transcript of what Donald Trump
said they conducted the interview Donald
Trump said quote it's so terrible what's
happening you know the left plays a
tougher game it's very funny I actually
think that the people on the right are
tougher but they don't play it tougher
okay so far it's unintelligible by the
way Trump goes on I can tell you I have
the support of the police the support of
the military the support of the bikers
for Trump I have the tough people and
they don't play it tough until they go
to a certain point and then it would be
very bad very bad but the left plays it
cuter and tougher so let's put aside for
a second the New Zealand shooting that
took place over the weekend even without
that we now have exactly the type of
comment that we can add to Trump's
subtle and sometimes not so subtle
fomenting of political violence remember
that in the United States political
violence exists almost exclusively by
the right okay this is Trump sort of
foreshadowing visit
confrontations I guess based on what
he's saying
between left-wing protestors who are
almost exclusively nonviolent and Donald
Trump's biker gangs as well as the
military and the police now you might
say hold on David Trump says police and
military but he doesn't mean that the
police and military are going to enforce
Trump's political views with violence
they are simply for law and order if the
left becomes violent in their opposition
to Donald Trump income the military and
the police and they will simply enforce
the law wrong okay that's a ridiculous
defense police have a job to enforce the
law period the fact that they support
Trump politically which Trump is
bringing up should have no place or
importance in the fact that if people
break the law
the police will step in now as far as
even mentioning the military the
military is not supposed to be used for
domestic law enforcement period there's
something from 1878 called the Posse
Comitatus Act commet ATIS not exactly
sure how it's pronounced which limits
the use of the federal government to use
the military for domestic policy
enforcement or domestic law enforcement
when Trump mentions even the possibility
of using the military in this way it's
outrageous and once again once you talk
about as Trump says the military is on
his side you're wading into very
dangerous and possibly illegal territory
and I was thinking Pat if you look at
who uses the military to enforce their
political positions it's not good
company it's exactly the authoritarian
types that were concerned Trump is so
impressed and enamored with yeah this
absolutely sounds to me like a veiled
threat it's kind of like Trump saying I
could beat you up if I wanted to but I'm
going to show restraint and I'm not
going to
I certainly hope it never comes to this
I hope we never see the police and the
military and the biker gangs fighting
against the people but if there is ever
time that it gets to that it may be if
Trump loses the election and wants the
fight back in some way doesn't want to
go down and I hope it never gets to that
but I think we're gonna talk about that
a little later in the show yeah we are
we've talked about that before and we
will talk about it again and and just to
put finalize so we've got the police and
the military then the biker gangs that
we're now kind of getting into the realm
of the absurd but Vladimir Putin has
actually used a Russian nationalist
biker gang called the night wolves who
are funded in part by the Kremlin to do
all sorts of political stuff in Russia
it's really vile it probably impresses
Donald Trump and once again these
comments I won't react a stik terrorism
is but these are the types of comments
that would fall under the umbrella of
stochastic terrorism publicly demonizing
or threatening a person or group which
statistically makes it likely that
someone will go and act out what it is
that is being suggested in this case
political violence by biker gangs the
police and military against the
political opponents of Donald Trump
Donald Trump Strunk that's an
interesting one very dangerous stuff and
I want to hear from you about it what is
your reaction in terms of Trump's
rhetoric to the New Zealand shooting
what is your reaction to Donald Trump's
thinly veiled threats to use the police
and the military and biker gangs to
crack down on political opponents by the
way political opponents that Trump
hasn't even said are violent I mean we
know that most of trumps political
opponents aren't violent the political
violence is coming from the right trumps
not even saying that this would be in
response to violence he's saying this
would be against his political opponents
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show follow
me let me know what you think and we'll
follow up on it later in the week I have
a very strange new video that suggests
Donald Trump either doesn't know where
Brazil is doesn't know what NATO is or
maybe maybe the most likely scenario is
both he doesn't know where Brazil is and
he doesn't know what NATO is and how it
actually works so let's step back and
I'll set it up for you Donald Trump's
with you on NATO and his relationship to
NATO has been erratic and frayed maybe
is how I would put it
sometimes NATO is quote as bad as NAFTA
to Donald Trump
Trump says he supports it other times he
says it's time for everybody to start
paying their fair share in terms of what
they vaguely committed to contribute to
NATO that gets us to yesterday where
Donald Trump welcome the new extremist
right wing president of Brazil Jaya
bourse balsan ro to the White House and
they gave a very bizarre news conference
during which the new Brazilian president
talked about gender and sexuality and at
one point Trump kind of reacted sort of
oddly wasn't clear if he was smirking or
exactly what his expression was but
there's another moment from this a press
conference which isn't getting the
attention that it should and it's
exactly about what I started talking
about Brazil and NATO NATO of course is
the North Atlantic Treaty Organization
na tio NATO it involves North America on
one side of the Atlantic Ocean and
Europe on the other side of the northern
Atlantic Ocean Brazil is of course in
South America but Trump suggested that
maybe one day Brazil could be a non NATO
ally or maybe a NATO ally and as usual
almost unintelligible from Donald Trump
but indicative of serious confusion or
ignorance are both by Donald Trump check
out this very strange video and listen
to the words that Donald Trump says as I
told president ball Senora I also intend
to designate Brazil as a major non-nato
Ally or even possibly if you start
thinking about it maybe a NATO ally have
to talk to a lot of people but maybe a
NATO ally which will greatly advance
security and cooperation between our
countries
he's just so dumb isn't he let's discuss
the possibilities of what this might
mean possibility number one is Trump is
just confused about what it means to be
a non-nato Ally and a NATO ally non-nato
Ally already means an ally of NATO
countries that is not actually part of
NATO which Brazil could be okay then you
have NATO ally which actually means part
of NATO but maybe in trumps mind NATO
ally means an ally of NATO countries
like in other words maybe Trump in that
that NATO ally is actually what non-nato
Ally of NATO means and I know I'm kind
of being confusing and it's because I'm
trying to untangle what confusion is
very evident in Donald Trump's mind now
if Trump actually wants Brazil to be
part of NATO if that's actually what he
means all of NATO needs to be rewritten
since it says only European countries
plus the United States or Canada and
Canada can join the last possibility and
this is kind of the wackiest most
cartoonish is that Trump thinks Brazil
is in Europe and therefore eligible for
NATO membership I don't know hilariously
after this proclamation was made NATO
was asked about it and they said go talk
to United States authorities they wanted
nothing whatsoever to do with trying to
parse what Donald Trump meant here so
that's the that we sort of gotten the
cartoonish hilarious stuff out of the
way let's now discuss the really
important things here number one the
more Trump talks about NATO the more we
realize he doesn't understand it which
makes it really dangerous and disturbing
that he so often is talking about NATO
and criticizing NATO without even really
understanding it has become as has
become extraordinarily clear the second
issue that is of significant concern is
that once again look at who Trump wants
in NATO Brazil is now headed up by yet
another one of these authoritarian sort
of dictate or wannabes who Trump is
always so impressed by and all of a
sudden Trump says we want Brazil and
NATO despite the fact that they're in
South America and are outside of the
operating treaty as it is written so
we're going from bad to worse Trump not
knowing the geography of Brazil it's
funny it goes along with everything we
know about Trump the real concerns are
as soon as you get another authoritarian
type in Brazil Trump immediately wants
to pull them into NATO and that's
actually a much broader concern which do
you think it is do you think Trump
doesn't understand NATO do you think
Trump doesn't know where Brazil is on a
map do you think it's both or something
else let me know
I'm on Twitter at D
Packman and the show is on twitter at
david pakman show okay we have heard
from Harvard Law Professor Lawrence
tribe who is sounding the alarm that he
believes Donald Trump is not going to
leave the presidency peacefully in 2020
and might specifically use bogus
national emergency declarations to
justify his re-election as a sort of
October Surprise type of thing so let's
step back before we get into Lawrence
tribes comments and and kind of think
about the context for a moment there was
discussion when Barack Obama was
president of Obama declaring Martial Law
to prevent the 2016 election from
happening and to stay in power
indefinitely
there was the idea of Donald of Barack
Obama I don't even know not holding the
2016 election in some other way or using
some kind of arcane legal mechanism to
try to become president for life now it
was ridiculous there was no merit to any
of those accusations Barack Obama had
never said anything of the sort Barack
Obama did not have authoritarian
tendencies under Donald Trump on the
other hand were hearing similar
allegations the difference being that
Trump does have a pattern in history of
those authoritarian tendencies
particularly related to the fairness of
elections Barack Obama never suggested
that president for life would be nice
which is something that Donald Trump has
said Donald Trump has talked about
Hillary Clinton getting three million
illegal votes started a voter integrity
commission election integrity commission
to look into it
with no evidence it found no evidence
but Donald Trump was willing to spend
untold amount of money in order to do
that Donald Trump refused to say that he
would accept election results that
showed he lost to Hillary Clinton in
2016 he has other authoritarian
tendencies that we've discussed not
directly related to elections we've seen
over the last few weeks some of his
flunkies like Sarah Huckabee Sanders the
press secretary start to float the idea
that Trump could only lose via some kind
of voter or election fraud or foul play
2020 which is of course an in defeasible
argument you can't possibly argue
against that if someone is asserting
that Michael Cohen said he's worried
that Donald Trump will not relinquish
control of the Oval Office if indeed he
loses in 2020 we've already done a
segment talking about how it's unlikely
in practice that it would actually be
allowed to happen by the military and by
law enforcement but all of these ideas
relate to ways that one might
hypothetically illegally seized power or
refused to relinquish it Lawrence tribe
brings us a different idea the idea
Lawrence tribe presented on MSNBC over
the weekend is that Donald Trump we know
he's willing to file to declare bogus
national emergencies over things that
are not actually emergencies or crises
the situation at the us-mexico border
being our example right now Donald Trump
Lawrence tribe suggests would use a
bogus national emergency declaration to
create a type of fear that would maybe
get him reelected in November of 2020
that's the idea here is Harvard Law
Professor Lawrence tribe saying it
himself we can't count on his being
voted out of office in 2020 he is
sufficiently corrupt and will probably
have enough help from not to friendly
foreign powers Russia Saudi Arabia
maybe Turkey so that we can't count on
removing this guy by an election and in
fact he may fabricate yet another
so-called national emergency to
influence that election what we have to
do is persistently gather the facts
right so what he is saying is not that
it would be an illegal seizure of the
White House or a refusal to accept the
results he's saying Trump could use
bogus national emergencies to get
reelected and of course in a country
where half the country doesn't vote half
the population doesn't vote and so many
people are voting based on incorrect
understandings of the world around them
it's not only plausible but it's
extraordinarily feasible to actually do
now
any president could do this right any
president as their term as their first
term is nearing an end and with a
reelection in doubt could do it but I
believe Pat that it's different with
Trump because he has a history of having
no problem lying about what even
constitutes an emergency many presidents
exaggerates the seriousness of
situations but Donald Trump has created
some of this whole cloth including with
the us-mexico border and importantly we
know that Trump supporters and his base
will 100% uncritically accept whatever
emergency declaration Trump makes so I
think that this is a more likely
scenario that Lawrence tribe points out
not that Trump will illegally refused to
leave the oval office but that we he
will engineer some kind of false
situation to justify his re-election
which will work yeah I think this is
more of an interesting conversation
sometimes we do talk about if Trump will
willingly vacate the Oval Office if he
does lose the election and I often think
that that is putting the cart before the
horse like we have to find out if he's
actually going to lose the election
first we have to have the election and
we should focus on that but if he
prematurely declares the national
emergency knowing that it's going to
garner him some support may put him over
the top that I do think we have to
actually think about it what that
emergency would be on the other hand I
don't know is it's gonna be something
more like a false flag or is it going to
be him making a mountain out of a
molehill like we did with this last one
on immigration well the most important
consideration no matter what it would be
is that Trump can't do any of this stuff
without Republican support or at least
Republican indifference because if
Donald Trump does fabricate any kind of
bogus emergency if Republicans don't
allow it right it's not veto-proof if
Trump declares a bogus emergency and the
House and Senate vote it down and Trump
vetoes that vote that veto can be
overridden if and this is the important
if Republicans decide they're not going
to allow Trump to use national
emergencies to try to get himself
reelected at this point the Republican
Party has demonstrated itself to be so
corrupt that they are likely to allow
Donald Trump to do whatever because of
so-called party unity or because a
Democrat would be war
or whatever specious justification they
come up with so I think that this is a
much greater danger than the sort of
cartoonish Trump barricades himself in
the Oval Office and refuses to leave
okay
let's talk about some of the promises
that have been made by the current
President of the United States some of
the promises that Donald Trump made
obviously were not going to be kept so
the classic is we're going to build a
wall across the entire us-mexico border
and Mexico's going to pay for it only an
extraordinarily ignorant or gullible
person would have believed that and of
course it hasn't happened but there are
a lot of other promises that are a
little more nuanced than thinking about
how they have not been kept and on
DailyKos there's a really good article
by John pur about this and there's a lot
to debate here about which are the most
obviously bogus promises that Donald
Trump made and which are more
embarrassing internationally versus
which are more embarrassing domestically
but it will just pick a few of them just
to think about so one big promise from
Trump was he's not going to cut Social
Security he's not going to cut Medicare
he made this promise many many times I
will point you to just one example a
tweet from May of 2015 where he said I
was the first and only potential
Republican candidate to state there will
be no cuts to Social Security Medicare
and Medicaid Huckabee copied me uh that
was not true the new budget which I told
you about last week that has been
proposed by Donald Trump cuts Social
Security by 25 billion it cuts Medicare
by 575 billion over the next decade
pathetic embarrassing I hope that people
hold Trump accountable for that even if
Republicans and Democrats in the House
and Senate don't allow it to become the
reality of the u.s. budget Trump claimed
many times that his tax plan would pay
for itself the idea was yes cutting
taxes significantly for the rich and
corporations will in the short run
decrease government tax revenue but it
will be so good for the economy
it will be so stimulative for the
economy that in the long run it will
increase tax revenue and pay for itself
the reality is this isn't happening
Trump has blown up the deficit to record
levels the budget is not going to
balance under Donald Trump as president
there obviously is no tax cut that is
paying for itself in even one year never
mind the long term the tax plan Trump
claimed would cost him a fortune that's
not true now of course he hasn't
released his tax returns so we don't
know the full scope of how he was
impacted by his tax plan but it's very
clear that if he's paying any federal
income taxes depending on what loss
carryovers he's using and other
mechanisms his federal tax rate went
down thanks to his tax plan there's no
way around it claims about growth Donald
Trump claimed that the US economy would
be at 4% annual economic growth maybe
even 5% he might have even at one point
suggested the idea of six percent in a
year GDP growth now we can debate
whether that was even reasonable from
the get-go we can debate whether for
five or six percent GDP growth is even a
good thing over the long term what we
can't debate is that it hasn't happened
we recently got the 2018 GDP growth
numbers and they were in the high twos
not 4% Trump said he would eliminate the
national debt over a period of eight
years in order to do that you need a
surplus you need to start using the
surplus to chip away at the national
debt so you can eventually get it to
zero over eight years I mean just forget
about it that's never happening and in
fact Donald Trump is adding to the debt
at record speed you can debate whether
it matters you can debate how worried we
should be about the deficit and paying
off the debt what you can't argue about
is that Trump promised to pay it off and
he's doing the opposite one other
example everybody will have health
insurance it's going to be beautiful
Obama care will be gone we'll put in
place something else everybody will have
health insurance it's not happening
okay the uninsured rate is up thirteen
point seven percent up to thirteen
points
percent last quarter and this also
relates to one of these promises that
maybe gets less attention remember Trump
said trade wars are good and easy to win
he's losing the current trade war with
China trade deficit with China has grown
not shrunk the revised NAFTA deal is
mostly stuff that was already under
negotiation when President Obama was
president it's combined with some new
ideas that wouldn't really do much even
if passed so the real question for me
Pat is which of these promises not kept
our most embarrassing internationally
and then most importantly our Trump
supporters going to hold him accountable
for any of these promises not kept or
will they merely say it's because of
Democrats that he hasn't been able to do
it I was wondering that too like will
these failed attempts at keeping his
promises caused him to maybe lose
reelection and I don't think that
they're really gonna hurt him I mean any
other politician it probably would you
have to make an effort to fulfill your
campaign promises and maybe Trump he has
made the efforts but he's been stopped
sometimes because of his own undoing
sometimes because Democrats have blocked
him but at any rate I think I think his
supporters are going to blame this on
Democrats and say that he tried to do
what he could and just failed at the end
of the day but he'll still support him
for the reason I tend to agree I tend to
agree I don't
ii-i've seen no evidence I mean listen
every once in a while we get a call from
a trumpet and they say this is the
really important issue and I need Trump
to do it I need Trump to do it and every
single time that I've pressed them and
said okay so if Trump doesn't do it like
there was one guy who was talking about
the wall are you not voting for him in
2020 and they back off immediately and
they say well no I mean listen I'm not
going to vote for a Democrat so that
that's exactly the attitude that makes
it not make a difference Trump seems to
have this completely immutable
unwavering base of support it seems to
be potentially as high as 35 32 percent
that just no matter what the guy does
even if he proverbially or or literally
shoot someone on Fifth Avenue will not
abandon him so what you know what this
gets us back to I I know I'm a broken
record at this point you've got a vote
that's it okay
Trump Trump's base is not going to say
it's time for him to go Republicans
don't appear to be ready or even
remotely interested in considering
saying it's time for Trump to go yes
bill well does gonna run against Trump
and John Kasich might run in the primary
and you've got a handful of Republicans
but big-picture Republicans in the
Senate aren't going to vote to remove
him his cabinet is not going to remove
him under the 25th amendment so the only
solution is to vote in 2020 we don't
know for who yet we are working our way
through these early stages of the
Democratic primary but if you're not
voting in November of 2020 it is a tacit
acceptance of Donald Trump remaining as
president of the United States I know I
won't be doing that and I'm gonna be
lobbying everybody in the audience hard
not to allow that to happen either make
sure you follow us on instagram at david
pakman show while you're there follow me
on instagram at David Pakman some
pictures oh this is actually kind of
interesting over the weekend I was in
Washington DC and at a restaurant really
nice restaurant of the waiter our waiter
said hey I watched the David Pakman show
and I took a picture with him and it's
up on my Instagram account at David
Pakman check it out after the break
what happens to your brain when you quit
Facebook even for just a month a very
interesting study gives us at least some
of the answers to that question so as
many of you know when we made our a
studio move several months ago we
redesigned the look of the David Pakman
show studio and in so preparing I spoke
to different people including Sam cedar
of the majority report and one of the
things I talked to Sam about is how he
set up the paneling that's behind him
and I purchased the same style panel to
be behind me and we integrated into the
set with a television and sort of
different coloring and lighting and blah
blah blah blah blah so recently someone
during one of my life
streams on YouTube sent the super chat
asking about it and then that person
called in to sam cedars show the
majority report and asked him about my
comment about it and Sam played my
answer to the question about it we're
now like three levels of Inception deep
and it's really funny take a listen to
this
Steven Robin says is it true that you
literally asked Sam cedar how to build
his set before you copied it yes I did I
mean the difference is I I've set it up
I've combined our old set which has this
screen behind me with similar paneling I
mean basically what what I copied was I
asked him how did he build the panel's
and he told me and I'm curious the I've
said that Sam helped me pack is going to
cut this segment and comment on this
segment and then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna cut the segment that he
comments on this segment and that's
basically going to be our business our
business memorize their plans yeah
that's exactly right so now I'm
commenting on this segment let me let me
make clear lest anyone be confused our
set is still in progress so more changes
are still forthcoming but there's a much
funnier part of this segment actually on
Sam's show which is that caller who
called in to Sam's show to talk about
the set piece it's the set element he
called and sort of complained to Sam or
I guess was kind of like incredulous
about the fact that during my youtube
live streams people send in paid
questions for me to answer through
something called super chat I find this
part hilarious he just seems totally
incredulous that people would do that so
I turn it on and he's reading questions
like comments and questions but they're
these YouTube super chats that you have
to pay for right and these questions are
in like $10 a pop people are asking like
what do you think about Cory Booker and
somebody paid like $10 to get him to
answer that right okay it's Kurt well we
have we also tried to and people do that
I mean I this is just what a this may be
my favorite majority report clip ever
the guy just can't believe that the
super chats are pouring in during my
live streams and then the caller is
angry not only about super chats but
about the fact that sometimes we'll have
a new member goal during live streams
before I take phone calls on the live
stream the problem again how much like
pay me to respond to what you're saying
getting to the good part okay sorry
so he's he says that he has a phone
number that he's going to take calls but
that he won't do it until he gets 10 new
subscribers 10 new patrons or whatever
member this is this is interesting
face holding he's got a gun to the
phones well and he's holding them
hostage right thing and guess what he
got there very quickly and it just seems
like you're leaving a lot of money on
the table my guy I'm trying to say well
I mean I mean so what should I do I
could say like we're gonna have we if we
get 10 members I'm going to start
answering the phones today we should do
that every day like guys we're new
members so this is just the best so now
we're going to create a never-ending
nested loop of comments on each other
segments about the set it's going to be
sort of like those Russian dolls or the
movie Inception someone super chatted me
to ask about Sam set then they called
Sam's show to talk to Sam about it
Sam played my clip in order to respond
to the call about the super chat on my
channel about Sam said now I'm
responding to Sam's comment about a
callers comment about a caller super
chat about my build out of the set which
resembles Sam said and then of course
the night path
progressive voice known as the
progressive TMZ on YouTube will comment
on the entire thing and then it'll all
sort of start over tomorrow well there
is a lot to comments on here and you did
promise me that no one was going to
notice that you copied Sam set so I'm a
little worried about the fallout here I
don't know where this is going to end up
but I'm not prepared for another five or
six response videos I don't think the
show is prepared either no well I'm
actually hiring Rudy Guiliani to
represent me on this matter on TV shows
because he's just so good at talking
people out of awkward situations so he
will now be talking about this going
forward by the way later today I'm going
to be asking Sam for his social security
and bank account numbers just so I can
figure out how those work before I start
using my own as well so many more
exciting segments to talk about